haven't seen you around you a tourist
nah i've been in baltimore for med
school oh actually i dropped out hot
smart and afraid of commitment every gay
man is tight
honey what are you doing here i lost my
keys wow you love a dramatic entrance
daddy's home
all right girl how are you feeling i'm
kind of nervous i've never performed on
like a real stage before i really want
this and you'll get it thank you mom
hey
the best way to get over someone is by
getting under someone else
[Applause]
you don't remember what happened
since that night this entire part of
myself that made me feel okay is gone we
cannot do this without you t
would you want to like hang out
[Music]
all of us survivors struggle every damn
day if one more person calls me brave
hey
i'm gonna keep them full on actually not
survivors hey hey hey stop thrivers
okay nevermind
[Music]
you got to stop blaming other people for
your problems
we got to take control of our lives
again
this is how we should be honoring the
victims
mingus has told me so much about you and
by it so much i mean he's been really
cagey mom can you stop please what's up
[ __ ]
what does someone wear to a sex party
tonight
our friends not as symbols but
[Music]
you know what that's called healing
i want to feel alive again
whoa whoa whoa whoa
are you gay
[Music]
you